[Musique]
New York
Buenos Aires
Rio
Lagos
Marseille Londres
Hambourg
Tokyo
Bombay Dakar
Hong Kong Jakarta
Hanoï Shanghai
Bordeaux
Nice
4 degrés
4 degrés c'est ce qu'il faut pour que
les habitants de ces villes menacés par
la montée des eaux voit leur habitation
sans autre forme de procès être englouti
il va sans dire que ces villes de plus
de 10 millions d'habitants pour celles
en dehors de l'Europe ne représente
qu'une fraction des territoires qui
seront et sont d'ores et déjà confrontés
à ce phénomène catastrophique
New York qui disparaît
difficile à imaginer et pourtant il ne
s'agit ni de prédiction d'ici à des
centaines d'années
ni de science-fiction
les réalités qui commencent à s'imposer
à nous semble aussi éloigner de ce que
nous aurions aimé nous faire croire que
quand le choc se produit
c'est la panique
solastalgie forme de détresse psychique
ou existentielle causés par la
destruction des habitats et par
extension par le réchauffement
climatique
elle se rapproche en cela de l'écho
anxiété
première définition que l'on trouve
lorsque l'on cherche solastalgie sur
internet Wikipédia
Jean-Marc Jancovici utilise dans son
dernier roman graphique le monde sans
fin une parabole que je trouve très
parlante
imaginez vous êtes à l'intérieur
d'un robot rouge flambant neuf
d'apparence
vous en êtes le pilote
à l'intérieur vous ne ressentez plus ni
le show ni le froid
vous allez vite
vous allez très très vite
vous produisez à peu près ce que vous
voulez à toute vitesse vous êtes
inarrêtable
mais quand vous sortez du robot
vous êtes des concertés
l'expérience était grisante mais à quoi
marche le robot
quel est son énergie qui la produit quel
est son coût
comment le robot a-t-il eu un impact sur
son environnement et avec quelles
conséquences
en définitive ce sont là toutes les
questions auxquelles répondent les
anxieux
et à raison face à notre modèle de
société les réponses lui font très peur
et quoi anxiété et cela stagi ce sont
des notions qui sont apparues très
récemment dans le langage courant
tout comme ces phénomènes sont avant
tout liés à des problématiques récentes
mais
honnêtement
je me demande bien qui dans la salle
face à tous ces constats dramatiques
ne ressent pas une inquiétude vis-à-vis
de l'urgence
alors bien sûr je pourrais dire que ma
génération est moi comme les autres nous
ressentons tout particulièrement cette
anxiété là
que si le nombre de consultations en
psychiatrie pour les jeunes et si élevés
c'est aussi pour cette raison
ce ne serait pas faux
la différence étant que nous vivons avec
cette urgence depuis notre naissance
mais dans le fond
est-ce que la vraie question ne serait
pas comment se fait-il que certains ne
ressentent pas des anxiété
est-ce que dans les faits
ce ne sont pas eux
le phénomène marginal
je m'appelle Mathias j'ai 16 ans et
quand je pense trop réchauffement
climatique j'ai très très peur
c'est un sentiment que je connais et qui
a commencé à m'aimer il y a déjà de
nombreuses années
et j'aurais aimé me rendre compte plutôt
que je n'étais pas le seul
parce que les chiffres me donnent raison
selon une étude très récente de l'OCDE
et du monde 80% de la population
française et convaincue de l'importance
d'agir contre le réchauffement
climatique
alors bien sûr il reste les 20% mais en
attendant la majorité du côté de
l'action de la science des écosystèmes
et puis
c'est 20%
ils n'ont pas moins bien vu le problème
ils ne sont pas moins en phase avec les
réalités
ils en sont peut-être tout simplement un
autre stade de l'acceptation du
réchauffement climatique
prenons les choses sous ce prisme vous
avez peut-être déjà vu la courbe du
deuil d'Elizabeth Kubler Ross qui est
utilisé en psychologie lors d'un
véritable deuil
pour moi cette courbe est intéressante
parce qu'elle peut aussi représenter ce
qu'il se passe lorsqu'on découvre
l'ampleur du problème climatique
elle représente très bien mon propre
cheminement
j'ai toujours été sensibilisé à
l'écologie mais c'est vraiment quand
j'ai eu 9 ans que je me suis rendu
compte que le problème était réel à
l'époque j'étais en CM2 et je recevais
un journal Le Petit Quotidien
un soir
le nouveau numéro
des images
beaucoup d'images
beaucoup d'images très marquantes pour
qui découvre que des maisons sont
vraiment submergées
que des populations migrent réellement
que des forêts prennent feu
que c'est la vraie vie
et que tout cela n'a rien d'une fiction
dystopique
pendant deux ans je n'ai plus voulu en
entendre parler
j'en ai voulu au monde entier et j'ai
été terrifiée puis vraiment abattu par
le poids de la menace qui semblait
planer au-dessus de nous
jusqu'à ce que deux ans plus tard je me
mette à la vie associative et militante
menée par une sorte de combinaison de
peur et d'espoir
j'ai passé de très très longues heures à
organiser des rassemblements des
manifestations
des créations d'affiches de pancartes de
publications Instagram
à me soucier de tout
avoir peu de reconnaissance auprès des
autres
à faire de mon mieux
qui demanderait cela un enfant de 12 ans
je l'ai fait parce que je voulais aller
vers ce renouveau puis vers cette
sérénité
et aujourd'hui je suis toujours
militante mais d'une façon un petit peu
différente peut-être plus centrée sur
mes perspectives d'avenir puisque
j'aimerais travailler dans le milieu du
droit de l'environnement
mais revenons à nos pourcentages
nos 80% sont convaincus de l'importance
de l'action climatique ils ont déjà fait
une partie du travail d'acceptation
il se situe donc dans la seconde partie
de la courbe à ma gauche
mais les 20%
ils font tout aussi bien partie de la
courbe
il se situe peut-être tout simplement
dans sa première moitié à ma droite
et comment ne pas les comprendre
comment finalement ne pas nous
comprendre parce que nous aussi nous en
avons été là nous aussi nous avons eu ce
choc fait preuve de déni ses colères ses
peurs c'est tristesse
certaines nous animent encore beaucoup
nous avons simplement commencé à les
transformer en action en tout cas en
volonté de changer les choses
et en somme ce sondage n'a été fait
qu'au début de l'été
et je suis à peu près sûr que les
sécheresses canicule
et feux de forêt en ont fait changer
d'avis plus d'un
la situation n'est pas drôle
en fait elle n'est même pas source
d'espoir
elle est dramatique
mais si je devais dire quelque chose à
chacun d'entre nous peu importe où nous
nous situons dans la courbe du deuil
c'est que nous ne sommes pas seuls
personne
n'ignore ce qui est le réchauffement
climatique
nous savons tous plus ou moins
et ça
cette unité là
qu'on le veuille ou non ces sources
d'espoir
le travail sera long
les délais sont courts et le chantier
est énorme
mais
nous pouvons
s'entraîner nos vies autour de la
question climatique nous pouvons
orienter nos métiers nos choix de vie
nos passions autour de cette urgence
maintenant nous devons amener le petit
écho qui est en nous plus loin
nous devons créer une nouvelle issue à
la courbe
celle du changement
celle de l'action
celle de la reconfiguration
montrons à ceux qui pensent que la
solastalgie est un phénomène marginal
que dans ce cas
eux-mêmes sont probablement aussi un
petit peu marginaux merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]